so you need strong management and you
need strong leadership and you need
stronger child
if you don't um
build your company to er to be scaly
like this
you can succeed because you can't be
you know everywhere the whole time
uh and you need to trust people in order
to
help you grow the business welcome to 20
minute leaders
just sit back relax and learn from the
leaders of today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by jventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with leumitech sponsored
by hippo insurance
opposed labs touring hillel at stanford
leap and in media partnership with ctec
welcome to another episode of 20 minute
leaders i'm joined today by semi cuts
and we're going to be talking about
customer retention in the digital world
and the customer journey
not so trivial meet remy katz co-founder
and ceo
of namogu a digital journey and
continuity platform
serving over 250 global brands in
e-commerce
with over 17 years of experience in the
e-commerce security commerce and
advertising spaces
hemi is an experienced visionary and
serial entrepreneur who builds
disruptive technologies
prior to co-founding the mogu kemi was
general manager of double verify
israel and co-founded sipai and risowed
earlier in his career himulet production
operations at lifeperson
was global business technology manager
for aladdin and managed it outsourcing
for buy net
chemicals welcome to 20 minute leaders i
guess all the way from the
mogu offices right yeah yeah we are now
at the
mogo offices one of the great room
salvador amazing namogu is not a it's
not a
small startup by now give me a little
bit of just for context before we dive
into what mogu does
a little bit of context as to you know
the number of people the fundraising et
cetera
yeah so founded in august 2014
so almost uh seven years basically
um around 140
employee we are going to be 200 by the
end of the year
four office locations so we have an
office here in italian israel
we have an office in boston new york
london
but we serve our clients globally mainly
in the us
europe not in america but globally
raised until now
69 million dollars and the last one was
40 million like in october 2019
and we have enough runway
it definitely sounds like it and you
know beyond
the fundraising and all these statistics
it just sounds like you're working on
on something really really fascinating
and something that is so
unique to the time we live in uh you
know
if i were to compare i guess an analogy
it would be like that i'm going to go
buy a newspaper at a kiosk in manhattan
somewhere on the street and then
a competing newspaper will come in and
say no no you should buy mine
but i'm going to let you uh
in that situation but now in the online
and tech world
yeah so actually we have a we have a
platform
so we call the platform digital
continuity
which we help e-commerce but we see
e-commerce as a broader sense and not
just a
regular e-commerce but also marketplace
fintech
travel tech and and so on so basically
every
company that is b2c usually that have
some kind of a funnel
um is a potential client for us
um so in the digital continuity platform
that we develop currently we have a
two products until the end of the year
we are going to have about
five products uh the main product and
this is how we start a mogul called
basically
customer journey uh or the phenomena
called customer journey hijacking the
product called
customer hijacking prevention which as
you mentioned
so imagine that you enter a nike store
and you see all kind of adidas ads it
will look very very weird
right so this is basically what happens
when you serve or browse
online to enact store for example
you can see all kinds of competitive ads
all kind of stuff that interfere
from browsing and it what you want to do
as a consumer and also
buying so it can be like if you look for
shoes it can be competitive shoes or
different kind of shoes
with sometimes lower price usually the
price
isn't right but when you click on it you
will go outside of nike show
a naked stove to a different kind of a
landing page
not necessarily an actual ecommerce site
and then i can lose you as a client it's
a bad experience
of course it helps all the kpis the
business kpi the conversion rate
uh the margin and all of that and in a
mobile we basically stop it so we
walked with company like tommy samsonite
jcpenney argos a lot of big brands
as i mentioned and we help them stop
this
customer hydrogen by basically cleaning
the website by the way it doesn't mean
that the website
got hacked or changed somehow it's
actually
on the user's side so you install some
kind of extensions
some kind of software sometimes
intentionally and sometimes
unintentionally that doing that
it's a a very large billion dollars
industry that that making out of it is a
shady
a place of a of advertising
and and we basically clean it we clean
the session
and by doing that we basically give our
clients
um a very clean experience
and for the merchant for the retail
basically uplifting conversion rate but
usually between 1.5
to 5 percent uplifting conversion rate
reaches a lot
that's really a lot that's huge and now
i i have to say that tell me one of the
things that i'm excited about
by thinking about this i'm you know i'm
thinking how you know how this problem
even came about
and i'd love to hear your opinion on it
because this is not a problem that we
faced
really at scale you know even 10 20
years ago
tell me what what happened in the world
of technology that led to this problem
emerging
so basically it happens a lot of years
but
of course it's grown as a as i mentioned
it's a
it's a shady of the end of advertising
industry but usually the writer doesn't
see it because
all happens on the client side they
don't see it unless
they experience it you know
personally by the way a true story
uh one of the first clients in a mogul
in the uk in manchester actually
we were with the meeting with the cto
and explain you know what is basically
customer journey hijacking how they pop
up and something
with because of your computer is
basically we called it infected or
hijacked
and the cto basically saying yes it's
happened all the time to my wife when
she brought
all kind of other sites so we said to
him
do you understand it's happened also
when consumer is browsing
your site as well and he said
you know what i didn't realize it until
now
wow happened he's a client's last for
the past six years by the way
uh so the majority of the retailer
doesn't even know
that it happened and unless you know
they they saw it somehow
unless we reveal it to them uh
but once they see it they want to test
it immediately
and usually they see the uplift pretty
fast
and continue with us you know i'm
imagining
you know the people that are working
internally with the company that they
have all these environments that are
very clean
that they get to go and see how the
website looks as if
you know they're perceiving it as a user
but they're forgetting that the users
are on their own machines in their own
browsers
with their own whatever extensions and
software's enabled
and you know obviously with with the
whole advertising market being
so incredibly huge you're gonna find
different softwares that
just allow for more advertising because
that's where the money is being made
but then you're introducing this problem
that your help that you're then helping
solve
it sounds like a whole big mess that
that now you're saying we're coming to
clean up
yeah it's all big mess by the way
sometimes it's not even on your device
it can be on a router on a coffee shop
or stuff like that so your device can be
completely clean and by the way those
hijackers it's not a
that they ask for a ransom or do bad
stuff to your device
they just want the money out of the
clicks
basically so it's a it's a money issue
if you have it on your device it doesn't
mean that your device is compromised or
something is going to happen to your
device
the majority of the time it's
interfering with with browsing for the
consumer
uh and interfering with revenue
uh for the re basically right
let me substance walk me back a little
bit to the beginning how
how do you come up with this how do you
come to this understanding because until
now and i've
i'm you know i see a lot of websites i
surf a lot and i'm also
a tech geek i never stopped to think
of the customer hijacking that is
happening which is also very targeted
because that is you know if you're
browsing a nike website
adidas is going to be the one
advertising not a refrigerator store
right yeah so by the way some of the
hijacking are
visual and some are non-visual i will
give you an example and then i will
answer your question so you can come to
the
site organically by the way and then you
will get refresh
and now nothing is changed on the site
so
the site looks exactly the same that it
was before
but now you have in the url an affiliate
code
so now nike need to pay someone although
you got to the site organically
and then sometimes they
mine bitcoin when you browse to
e-commerce because usually e-commerce
are very fast
so they use this time to mine your
bitcoin
and then in interfere with your browsing
so the majority of the time it's
do visual but sometimes it's non-visual
and sometimes it looks
very very embed into the site so even
people that look for it doesn't really
see it
and so how basically we started the
mogul so before the mogo
i had another startup called zipai which
basically
was an affiliate for e-commerce
uh we basically knew what the
clients we want to purchase so seek for
purchase and then we offer it on
different
social networks back then it was
pinterest
and twitter yeah it was back then
uh to drive traffic into uh
into e-commerce and then some of the
companies that do the hijacking
and it can be like a public company and
it could be like a
two guys on the garage that basically
came to me and my partner which we had
around
2.53 million active users per
month which is a lot uh to basically
start inject stuff
into our user base
my company eventually got acquired
but by someone by actually
a company in france are doing hijacking
that now they are blocking
but i am just absolutely amazing
yeah i understand that there is a gap uh
in the
in the e-commerce space which e-commerce
basically lose a lot of money because of
that
and this is basically how the mogul
came to life by the way namogu the one
that doesn't know
it's actually a hebrew word which is
faded away vanished and this is
basically what we do to
hide your kills amazing
and just just uh just amazing and
was it off the go a success that
immediately you go and you talk to
people you talk to investors and friends
and everybody says like wow yeah this is
a huge problem
we're in or was there or was there some
skepticism behind there
no it was from the beginning like a huge
problem
uh by the way today we sold not that
no not only that we have a different
product
as well we have basically a product
called intel
based promotion uh which is based on an
acquisition that we did last year
called personality but we tweaked it
a lot uh to be for e-commerce and much
more broader solution basically
instead of having all kind of site-wide
promotion
and give everyone like 20 of free
shipping and all of that
what we do what basically our platform
is doing
we know uh like in 100 milliseconds from
the
minute that you get into a site what is
your in what is
the intent uh for you to come into the
site so we know if you can't
browsing we know if you're coming to
return a product we know if you're
coming to purchase
and of course changing it along the uh
the customer journey itself
and this is basically what we do so
instead of giving
a promotion for everyone of 20
discount so you'll give us a playground
you give us
between 0 to 20 or 5 to 20
and the engine knows what exactly
trigger what kind of promotion to give
you
and what kind of level promotion and
what time in order
for you to buy so we know uh
what is your intent of purchase what is
your intent for abandonment and a lot of
other different a variety of
points and then we all feel in real time
uh the promotion that the client decides
so basically
we change from a rule-based
uh segmentation incentives
into a one platform that can give you
everything and by doing that again
uplift your conversion rate uplift your
margin
lower down your average discount for
example if it's a discount
and e-commerce love this
it sounds incredible i mean the problem
of figuring out
intent you know it's known to be one of
the toughest problems to solve
and so i can only imagine that with that
only this
only this aspect is you know is a
completely world of its own which which
part of this whole system
is most enjoyable by you so when you
look at this company you've built
either leading 140 people raising the
money
seeing the customers and onboarding them
which part for hemi is really the
the big show actually you know in the
corona it's a bit different but
before the coin i travel a lot uh
worldwide
to see our clients stores or even
browsing online
or someone that is browsing online and i
see some of our clients
it's and i know that you know our
solution
is on their website or protect the users
or give them better experience
it's a great job wow
and and so how was the compensation for
that in this past year of corona
uh you mean in terms of uh what clients
what did you find yourself doing this
year of corona when you can't travel you
still want to see the clients
first of all like everyone we buy a lot
i think e-commerce especially in israel
grow a lot
uh during the corona so
all of us you know uh
acquire a lot of things the majority of
them we don't need but we still acquire
them because we love
buying and
i knew a lot of new clients a small one
big ones
which was great growing the team to 140
and you're starting out what what do you
find
you know non-trivial in this feat you
know we're not talking about growing as
you guys we're talking about building an
entire company across four different
locations around the world
three continents how do you how do you
deal with
you know 140 people so you need strong
management
and you need strong leadership and you
need stronger child
in order to do that otherwise otherwise
you can do it
when you scale it's not like 20 or 30
people or even
50 people on the same location now you
have people on different location
that talks to and sell very
large client um which
they need to be independent you need to
be scalable
on all aspects from you know the
developer that develop stuff and need to
be more automatically
up to the sales person that in the
customer success that talk to
the clients if you don't
um build your company to
er to be scaled like this you can
succeed
because you can't be you know everywhere
the whole time and you need to trust
people in order to
help you grow the business and this is
also
why we invest a lot in people so we see
people people are the most important
asset in the company uh
and we invest a lot uh also in the
corona time which was very hard to do
because everyone work from
home different for the children all the
family
you know where everyone is all around
but still it's very very important so
you know if i need to give wanted
you know advice to uh to young
entrepreneur is to invest in people
because in the end
this you know where uh will come back to
you
amazing i have a few more
questions they're not about namogo and
not about customer hijacking and
nintendo they're more personally about
you and i want to take you back to your
childhood
what fascinated you as a kid what was
what was one of your you know passion
hobbies or favorite subject in school
for example
uh i don't want i don't know how
you pronounce it in english but uh
citizenship yeah so citizenship
it's a lot of uh you know political how
the difference party has walking i know
it's a it's a bit odd
but even today i feel much like
to hear about the politics not just you
know the corn climate but
you know all the time uh
so i really really like
politics as well and also
i was doing a lot of cycling as well
cycling wow yeah very very cool
i going forward to inspiration
and role model somebody that inspires
you along the
wow like this is a story that i can
learn from as i go on my journey
so it was on my
i think somewhere in the military but i
really like
richard branson you know the founder of
uh
virgin and everything i i read a lot of
you know books about him what he did
i really really like how he builds
and how we invent and how we solve
everything so he's really a role model
for me
and i think it's extraordinary his
personality his brain and his
his compassion and what are three words
that you would choose to describe
yourself with
if i were to ask you who's hemi
well
it's a hard question so i think
the majority of the time i'm a bit quiet
so i i know how to listen
i i react fast okay
which is something that is i think is
very unique for me so i know how to
go out from you know all kind of
a different and odd situation
um and i want to think myself as a
visionary as well
i love it
it sounds amazing and and you know i
think it's a perfect
perfect example of you know it's a whole
new world that we live in and we're just
starting to understand the implications
of really you know our digital life and
and where there's
amazing opportunities like what you've
done and so thank you for sharing this
with me and
and for the time and stay safe and stay
healthy thank you
okay great thank you take care
[Music]